je crois que s'ils
saluent alors le boulot ça a été
qu'est-ce que tu l'aies
dans quelles facs tu va envoyer ton
dossier j'sais pas
on est en train d'en parler avec josh
donc tu as gardé ce plan suivent piocher
dans la fac qu'il choisira toi et maman
vous êtes des amours de jeunesse me dis
surtout pas que vous étiez fait l'enfant
l'autre fargo il va me faire dire qu'on
était fait l'un pour l'autre ouais c'est
ce que je veux on était là
tout est compliqué mais
il ya toujours une solution
[Musique]
déjà vu cette voiture la banque
gens sont pas là pour ça
accroche toi
on n'a pas une minute à perdre il faut
qu'on parte les ont trouvés
3 / adieu les états unis adieu exemple
qu'est ce qu'il a fait je suis désolé
prépare ton sac par conti minutes
qu'elle pointe dans la merde en réalité
qui plus est certaines choses seraient
parfois
bien sûr que si on peut tout réparer
mais pour ça il faut pouvoir aucun homme
apprécié cette situation
malheureusement si tu ne prends pas la
bonne décision c'est ce qui va arriver
[Musique]
ce qu'on s'apprête à faire ses pourrait
passer pour un très mauvais exemple ça
va être une super aventure
[Musique]
demande de fugitifs se dirige vers le
mexique
j'avais prévu de phoque et avoir une vie
je peux pas rester en cavale avec vous
trois jusqu'à la fonte bijoux
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait un succès
c'est difficile à expliquer
[Musique]
vous m'intéressait beaucoup si vous êtes
c'est lui que tu joues et parce que vous
êtes
permettez moi de vous dire que nous
n'apprécions pas beaucoup cette
conversation
pourquoi vous lui faites ça
pourquoi lui il vous fait ça
vous coûte à lyon
[Musique]